you know we learn and again our
boundaries may change one day depending
on the situation and when it comes to
kendall jenner's relationship with her
boo devin booker yeah things seem to be
changing all right a source tells e.t
the famously private model who's kept
her romance under wraps is now a bit
more comfortable with pda adding they've
never seen kendall like this it's not
always easy
the couple recently packed on the pda at
the us open check out kendall and devin
sitting in a sweep at one point the
lovebirds snuck in kisses and leaned in
close our source says they were all over
each other and didn't care that everyone
could see quote she's really into him
she's always had love for him even when
they were separated but she's more into
him now than ever i like to keep my
private life pretty private so
i try my best but at the same time i
don't i don't like to let
being seen out in public with someone
like affect my everyday life
and over the years kendall's kept it
that way keeping her relationship with
devin pretty out of the spotlight since
they were first linked in june 2020.
it's a private matter it's not really
for anybody else to to judge or know i
feel like it's always worked better for
me that way fast forward a year into it
and she confirmed they were dating
what's happening with you and devin
booker
um he's my boyfriend
you're together yeah
since then devin and kendall have shared
a few cute social media posts together
but by june two years into their
relationship they broke up a source told
et at the time kendall felt like they
were on different paths and they weren't
on the same page about their future
together but the source noted they left
the door open for a possible
reconciliation which clearly happened oh
my god just be cool it's fine our source
says devon and kendall's on-again
off-again romance has changed her
perspective on relationships and she's
more serious than ever despite all her
sisters being moms and settling down
kendall was never interested in that
she's always been focused on her career
and her friends but lately her
priorities have shifted and she's made
space for devin and the big question
here will we see the basketball pro on
season two of the kardashians i feel
like i'm becoming my own woman
but i really want to be my own boss yeah
don't hold your breath i think like a
cool part about kylie and i growing up
on the show
and something that maybe we don't take
for granted is you know we got to see
things happen before we got you know
older our older sisters kind of
experienced a life that we got to view
and so just from a really young age i
think both kylie and i kind of knew what
we wanted to keep
off the show or what we wanted to keep
to ourselves and um
yeah i think that it's kind of as simple
as that
[Music]